[Music]
well Democrats have stolen years of your
life years you'll never get back in the
search for Russian cohesion we don't
have any of that evidence yet but the
hunt for it left broken credibility
across the board and particularly at the
Justice Department the FBI for example
started spying on Carter Paige a US
citizen who went to the Naval Academy
and served as a naval officer based on a
politically motivated still
uncorroborated series of allegations
from fusion GPS which was in a fact on
arm of the Hillary campaign now fusion
GPS founder Glenn Simpson is pleading
the Fifth Amendment to avoid testifying
before Congress congressman Devin Nunez
represents California and he's the
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee he joins us tonight mr.
chairman thank you very much for coming
on
so before I thank you talk about Glenn
Simpson and why you think he might not
be testifying to your committee I just
want to get an update on the documents
that the rest of us were supposed to see
most specifically the FISA warrant that
allowed the spying that the Obama
administration did on Carter page are we
ever going to find out the justification
for that well years of your life not
getting back many Americans including
myself I think that's such a great
opening Tucker we are very frustrated
that we have not been able to get these
documents out the president ordered them
and then you had rod Rosenstein who got
in the middle of it which I'd be fine if
Rosen Stein got in the middle of it if
he had a real reason but every time he
said that he has a reason to block this
information he never it ends up being
false and now you have rod Rosen Stein
who won't even testify before Congress
so are we going to see this information
I guess we're waiting the president put
the IG in charge of it Horowitz I don't
think that was a good idea but the end
of the day that's what we're counting on
it's I mean at some point you start to
ask like what's the point of voting
I mean you elect a new guy and but the
same people are still in charge still
sorting what you want I mean it does
kind of call into question of democracy
itself do you think any member of
Congress would be willing to take the
risk and just say you know what as an
American I think you have a right to see
this that person's yeah the challenge
yeah the challenge where that is is
is is you know we can talk about we
could hypothetically go down to the
floor of the house and talk about it
we've talked about this on your show but
you know we don't have the actual
documents in our possession we can't
March them down to the House floor slap
them down so those documents are in
possession by the Department of Justice
and the FBI there should be no reason
why the this I mean we've been very
narrowly focused on 20 pages of the last
FISA that rod Rosenstein signed and I
don't think that rod Rosenstein should
be in the decision-making process of
whether or not the American people
should see these or not I agree with
that completely so let me just ask you
to sum it up since you are privy to much
more information than the average person
as the chairman of the committee that
could a pivotal committee have you seen
and and answer this knowing that in the
end we're all we're gonna know all the
facts because they're always revealed in
the end have you seen any evidence that
there was a collusion between the Trump
campaign and the Russian government
honestly no I have not and in fact I've
seen the opposite that we know for sure
and I know you're gonna ask me about
Glenn Simpson in a second here but and I
hate to jump ahead but simply who was
work Hill he was working for the
Democrats
okay the Clinton campaign he got
information from Russians that
information was fed into the FBI okay
Glenn Simpson was spreading that
information out to the press and now we
know that Glenn Simpson was actually
meeting with the FBI
long before he testified to Congress
that he was meeting to the FBI so this
is somebody who likely lied to Congress
should probably be prosecuted which is
most likely why today he pled the fifth
and refused to testify before Congress
it is so frustrating to watch this as a
voter I have to say I think I speak for
many other voters mr. chairman thank you
very much for everything you're doing
always a pleasure thank you Tucker